[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous
donc comme on vient de l'annoncer biologistes
travaillant au laboratoire de
reproduction et de développement des plantes ok je
pense que je devrais et donc je ne parlerai
pas tant de mes recherches aujourd'hui mais
préférerais parler de la biologie
comme science pour  les uns les autres, donc je pense
que la plupart d'entre vous auront une
vague idée très générale de ce que la biologie
comprend réellement et eh bien, il n'y a en fait rien d'
étonnant parce que si vous regardez la
définition que vous aurez enfin le
dictionnaire normal la science de la vie
eh bien c'est un très  définition générale en
effet, mais ce type de
définition résume très bien les
défis majeurs auxquels nous, biologistes, en tant que
communauté, sommes confrontés des centaines de
milliers de plantes et d'animaux à
poncer et chaque espèce vient avec de
nombreuses questions,
ce qui signifie des millions de questions qui peuvent
potentiellement être posées  et très souvent très
souvent seulement un accès partiel à l'information
et par conséquent très souvent doivent être
très doux avec o  nos conclusions ce n'est
pas toujours possible d'être très précis dans
notre hypothèse et un physicien alors
ami à moi a très bien résumé ce problème
la blague qu'il m'a racontée sur
beaucoup de biologistes il a dit il y a ces
biologistes physiciens et mathématiciens
assis dans le train ils longent un terrain
et  ils voient un gars blanc le biologiste
dit immédiatement oh les filles sont
ici dans cette partie du pays le
physicien a dit eh bien elles ne s'accrocheront pas
il n'y a qu'une seule vache blanche dans un champ
dont l'
imitation dit bien tu sais la seule
chose que je  voir est une vache dans le champ et elle
a au moins un côté blanc et je pense que
cela résume très bien la
différence entre ces différentes
sciences alors que les mathématiciens et les
physiciens peuvent être très précis cela peut être
quantitatif dans leurs expériences très
souvent les biologistes doivent élever leur
première hypothèse hypothèse initiale juste
sur une ou deux tasses j'aurais dû montrer
la réponse alors quelles sont les solutions
pour résoudre ce problème  Je suis
bien sûr que les biologistes ont de la place pour des
solutions et je ne vais pas entrer dans
tous les détails, je n'aurais pas le temps pour
cela,
mais je voudrais tout d'abord souligner deux points
sur l'importance des
systèmes normaux en ce moment des milliers  des
scientifiques étudient un
nombre limité d'autres systèmes souris les paradoxes végétaux sur
lesquels je travaille drosophile
la mouche des fruits et l'idée est qu'en
limitant nos recherches, un nombre limité
d'espèces seront en mesure de découvrir un
certain nombre de principes de base  qu'au moins,
nous l'espérons, sera applicable à un large
éventail d'espèces. Le deuxième point que je voudrais souligner
est l'importance d'une sorte
2:53 la nature a publié cet article également
un grec et chiffrant la structure de l'
ADN et il a découvert que  le code ADN
pour information et ensuite ce code peut
être transmis pour soi qui filles
d'une génération à l'autre
et cela a conduit à l'idée générale je suis
sûr que beaucoup d'entre vous auront cette
impression aussi bien que l'ADN co  contient des
informations pour construire un
organisme entier pour présenter un concept comme cette
image à mes élèves c'est une peinture
par aimant anticipant quelque chose pour les vôtres
et en effet pas seulement en raison d'une mauvaise utilisation d'une
dame disant bien je pense qu'il était possible de
prédire avec un certain degré de
précision  quoi que ce soit qui en sortira
cependant par les technologies, les entreprises resteront
et elles pourront modifier l'
information génétique de telle sorte que
tous aient des cultures conçues sur mesure en
même temps le biologiste j'ai
découvert qu'en fait qu'ils  contenir un ce n'est
pas un simple programme informatique comme on
pense parfois qu'il est respecté par l'
élection de divers échantillons
mr.  présentation générale de ce résultat
l'idée est une température entière les
insectes sont plus petits ils ont exactement
la même information génétique donc cela
veut dire que l'ADN dans les gènes je ne viens pas
pour la taille de cet animal
on voit des exemples d'oxygène si on regarde
ces moments pourraient avoir une information très génétique
ou une forme identique dont
ils sont passionnés vecteur est complètement
différent et c'est parce qu'ils
interagissent qui doivent s'adapter à leur
leur environnement et si nous aurions
été devant des graines par exemple même en les
connaissant  les pièces n'auraient pas été en
mesure de prédire avec une quelconque
précision l'architecture précise de
la plante sortant de cette graine,
alors qu'est-ce qui ne va pas avec notre
hypothèse selon laquelle l'ADN est une sorte de
programme informatique de Richards bien que
seuls les biologistes soient  commencer à
réaliser qu'en fait les systèmes vivants ne sont pas des
ordinateurs ce sont des systèmes complexes maintenant
qu'est-ce qu'un système complexe un système complexe
est dans le système co  composé de nombreux
éléments qui interagissent très souvent
toujours en série et ce système a une sorte
de comportement négatif et ce
comportement collectif ne peut pas être identifié, c'est-à-dire
lorsque vous
des parties individuelles parfois et peut-être connaissez-vous
cette expression pour tenir cela plus
que certaines des parties dans  en d'autres termes
, le comportement linéaire long de ces systèmes les
systèmes ne sont pas limités juste la biologie
il y a de nombreux exemples dans les sociétés humaines l'
économie l'Internet bien sûr des
millions des millions d'ordinateurs sont connectés les
uns aux autres
personne ne décide vraiment si une structure de
ce réseau est l'économie et ainsi que
moi  nous venons de dire que nous avons cette
propriété de comportement cognitif donc les propriétés
émergent de cette loi et ces
propriétés émergentes ont une propriété vraiment étonnante
de systèmes complexes que nous venons d'illustrer à
nouveau en utilisant cette fois un exemple du
niveau du marché boursier il y a ces
centaines de niveleuses qu'ils sont allés  vous
pourriez dire un gros disque et ils veulent des
gens très riches et comme résultat  t
dans chaque entreprise est enregistrée sur
ce marché boursier particulier, quelle que soit
la valeur très précise, personne ne décide
où cette variable va être,
même collectivement, ils ne le décident
pas, c'est simplement le résultat de leur
comportement collectif et, dans ce sens, de
systèmes complexes  sont très différents des
autres systèmes tels qu'une phrase d'horloge elle
appartenait à l'horloge
il y a beaucoup d'éléments en interaction
n'auront pas trop de propriétés émergentes
vous voulez juste que l'horloge indique très
précisément l'heure et tous ces
systèmes vivants sont aussi des systèmes complexes des
milliards de  les molécules interagissent
[Musique] les
systèmes encore une fois c'est difficile pour moi de
m'épuiser mais l'idée c'est d'abord
d'identifier les composants clés c'est ce
qu'on fait depuis 30
ans car l'ADN c'est juste il
faut aussi caractériser leurs interactions
ils doivent  identifier les propriétés pour
analyser ces systèmes à différentes
échelles et, très important, nous devons
être extrêmement précis dans  nos observations
espèces aucune preuve
donc je pense que nous pouvons être
optimistes c'est parce que d'autres proposent nos
recherches à un nombre limité d'espèces
comme je viens de le dire et deuxièmement la
technologie a évolué de manière vraiment
spectaculaire il est maintenant possible de
séquencer l'ADN  d'un individu dans le
nôtre l'analyse peut prendre plus de temps
mais nous avons un ordinateur très puissant pour
analyser cette information
des microscopes très puissants et sophistiqués
pour évaluer les interactions entre le
moment et les molécules de jean et par
conséquent je pense que comme je viens de le dire nous pouvons  sois
optimiste et avec le physicien et un
mathématicien
tu pourras dire que quatre vingt quinze virgule
neuf pour cent des couleurs sont blanches et
en plus ça pourra aussi expliquer
comment le venu est devenu blanc et même pourquoi
il est là et puis avec ça
message optimiste je voudrais et
ma présentation et merci pour votre
attention
Merci
[Applaudissements]